look at her son i can't get over i know
we've talked about this before but her
son
it got an attractive human being if he
gets arrested for a crime and has to go
to regular jail oh his ass is getting
tore up whoa well i mean i've never see
that's him right there that's him look
at his eyes wow
i'm not a gay man but [ __ ] it
i mean that's astonishing how beautiful
he is
he's obviously a big model i mean i
don't like his hairy chest that gross is
now but i know but he's got a face on
him like i've never seen he's very gay
it's real is he insanely gay of course
look at his friends
yeah
in the back i mean just a gorgeous human
being it is what it is man yeah he's
abusive what if he ain't gay oh he is i
guarantee he is god you don't dress like
that chevelle prince
prince was they they always say prince
was getting all the hoes sure and and
bros
they never said that how's their host
bros and ho he gets them all
all right his hair is insane
private person what does he say he's a
private person surprised he don't tell
nobody oh dude we don't need to look
into this
we're all set no no we yeah we got this
i'm pretty sure yeah case closed
we call this first 48 seconds that's
right there you go
that's right oh there it is there's
hairy legs too
yeah i wish we would shave down if he
was my man you know what i'm saying now
now let me ask you gonna be a twin girl
regular dude you're a bro
if you had that face and that look how
would you even if you cut his hair he
looks it's still feminine he looks very
honey yeah yeah he's just a pretty human
being yeah that's right that's the
reason why i do well i mean you almost
have to embrace you gotta [ __ ] him
no what
hold on let me finish i thought you were
saying what would i do if he's your
friend if he's your buddy yeah and
you're a straight man yeah of course you
[ __ ] him no that's what i'm saying yes
and it's not gay no way but it's about
it dude what happens is you get drunk
and he's looking at you and you're like
i'm gonna go with those pouty little
ladies yeah it's like those blue eyes
and you're all it's you're nantucket
you're a nasty and the wine's flowing
and the wine's flowing and he's oh we're
[ __ ] broke
and by the way you're [ __ ] him face
on face it's not yeah
you're passionate you're alone
and and then i find out and i'm like
that's hard
i've gotten hard in that ad i go i go
and i go dude weiner the wiener
wiener to wiener i don't call it
because he is very he's so androgynous
you can't put yourself that makes me gay
it is what it is look at his hair
it's nuts man yeah he's he's uh he likes
to have a good time well look at the way
he's you know i by the way i don't know
if it's his mom or him at some point you
know
i'm confused myself
that's what i'll tell you guys i'm like
dude i think i hooked up with elizabeth
earlier
are you sure yeah i don't know dude
you decide what am i going to do
she kept listening machine gun kelly
which was confusing it could be the sun
there's no difference dude i don't know
what to say boy she's she's uh look at
him with the model which one which one's
female there i don't know i don't know i
don't know
i mean i i mean seriously look at his
hair you literally can't tell he just
has a lot of feminine he has a lot of
estrogen in his body
that's fine he might be intersex i don't
[ __ ] know
either way it's all good is what i have
to say that's what i'm saying it's all
good look at that photo
fantastic the hair is fantastic
with a rubik's cube i see i wouldn't see
you see how they put he's so handsome
that's not enhancing me that's double
he's gorgeous i'd say that i agree he's
just a gorgeous human being this coming
from a straight man straight as it gets
i i i'm telling you that nantucket the
wine is flowing
he would be so all over you curious
brendan let's go swimming waiting and
i'd like yeah yeah walk in my trunks
let's go we don't have any oh we don't
have trunks in the point [ __ ] it yeah
yeah [ __ ] it and then you look you're
like i'm a little thick
i like that i think you mean manly oh
dude it's on dude and nobody's around
and it's his nightmares
stay flat well get on the back of my
bike
i'll paddle us there
i'll pedal this there oh i have bad news
this big mansion only one bad daddy ah
[ __ ] you're gonna cuddle you would
cuddle him that's the [ __ ] up thing
there's a man out there that you would
wiener
we're not going butts to nuts
we're going weiner to wiener dude
gonzo on gonzo knows
where is his pop